we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk gonna be back in studio it's a new
year a new queer and we're here how the
hell are you i want to be here yeah
trying to keep the rhyme going we got
the beer jew i'm good man yeah how you
doing good good i'm feeling fresh i
showered uh it's not that cold today
i'm back it's nice out it's nice i
bought a new shirt look at that that's
not sorry anything too tight it's a
little tight ah i knew it wait i mean
it's just
maybe it works what do you think i think
he's getting fatter
all right that i can change
but i bought this shirt in des moines so
i can't remember
yeah damn it's a little tight [ __ ]
where'd you go i went to the mall
there's nothing to do with which store
in the mall though uh express for men
had a 60 off sale i knew there was a
cash
i would never go into express for men
mark wants to be a jew so badly he only
shops at discounts
that's true yeah i mean i stole it but
uh
you know what's funny i believe him
yeah
it's a joke for the bob but i could see
him doing it i stole one and bought one
did you really yeah you stole a shirt
yeah how did you steal it how'd you get
it down to the store i wore i put it on
ripped the tags off there was no sensor
by the way ripping the tags off shows
like you intentionally did it like
there's pretty well you think you did it
by accident i'm not saying you can no
longer walk out and be like oh i forgot
well
oh i forgot i was wearing it i forgot i
ripped the tags off well i wouldn't let
them see the tags no if they catch you
you can no longer say oh it was an
accident sure sure but i if they caught
me i would it would go beep beep beep i
go oh [ __ ] sorry
it is funny that mark like he's getting
a little better because he's only
stealing from sales yes that's you could
tell he's like working out he's not
stealing from like banana republic he's
stealing from express remains sixty
percent off it's progress that's a
hundred thank you
100 off five figure disc but my biggest
my biggest accomplishment was i did
conan one night i needed a nice shirt
went to the mall in la put a shirt on
wore it on conan with the buzzer
honestly wow i went around conan going
could anybody crack this code and get
this thing off of there and they're all
like what are you doing no we have we
have uh classy celebrities on the show
usually who don't steal their clothes
exactly but did it with the sensor on
you were you were reckless yeah
to steal the day of a late night like if
he gets arrested they have to get a
different guest that's a good point i
didn't think about that well what would
you get a slap on the wrist like it's
okay the first guess is winona ryder
nothing will go wrong here
you don't go to jail for that do you
i don't know one shirt probably not
probably not but it's not grand theft
auto here
[Laughter]
i did kill a prostitute
but that's true what are we drinking
beer jew
today we're drinking uh gin gimlets as
mark requests wow
we're gonna soften them up a little bit
with a little bit of saint germain and
that's it just sweeten them up a little
bit sometimes you sweeten them up with
so it's saint germain gin and lime juice
yeah basically that's all a gimlet is a
gimlet really is just gin or vodka and
lime juice and that's it but i'm gonna
soften up for you guys just this one
time oh boy
thanks boy uh with that shirt who's uh
who's running the surf shop
you know who he looks like he looks like
spider-man if he was on the jersey shore
[Laughter]
that's it yeah
i don't think i got enough uh you know
it's killing time and that's it so that
movie is that's like
i love how people are like it saves
cinema but it's like only for superhero
movies yeah it's not like people are
running into the movie to see belfast
you know or macbeth yeah i saw it there
you go
but i want to see belfast spider-man is
uh tom holland now
it's all three of them this time what
yeah they did like a thing where all
three of them are in it geez i can't
keep up this two minutes
hey
hey
cheers
never had a gimlet this is what i used
to order when i was underage because i i
thought they wouldn't card me
so i say can i have a gin gimlet they'd
be like well surely he's over 40.
like 17. oh boy that's tasty
it's like uh like a white man's
margarita
this is a margarita fruit
this is a margarita for people who own
slaves
there you go that's pretty much on the
mark yeah
this is good is this an old lady drink
is that what you're saying gimlets
gimlets are almost exclusively an old
white lady with pearls drink is that
right for sure absolutely you want an
ice cold gimlet up and if you put
anything except gin and lime in there
they're gonna yell at you and probably
find the manager so they should call
this a a karen on the rocks
we'll go to the carlisle after this and
we'll hopefully get picked up by a
strong man yes
that's some kind of baron
a gentleman caller yeah there you go my
wife's barren
all right
baron davis all right baron vaughn
he's on everything that guy he's on
shows yeah he's on like every tv show
frankie and shirley what is it called
grayson frank grace and frankie yeah
yeah lily tomlin
still going i love it
i love lilly thomas yeah she's great i
grew up with lily tomlin that big uh
rocking chair uh laughing
all right i never watched it it was big
it was the reruns played when i was a
kid but jane fonda still [ __ ] would
you oh yeah
are you kidding i want to break her in
half it'd be so easy i think that'll
take yeah
you breathe on her a little harder ah
[ __ ] i mean i can't i feel like if you
undo her blouse her whole body falls
apart but uh she's still hanging in i
mean she's gotta be what's
600
how old is she let's see
got to be 80. i bet more really i mean
she was literally in vietnam so let's
see what
yeah she was in vietnam what do you mean
in vietnam she went there and advocated
for the enemy do you remember this whoa
whoa
jane
nothing oh oh the movie no she went to
vietnam and went to the other side
and said
uh americans should stop bombing you
people
and she was sitting there on a
what are those things called those big
anti-aircraft guns yeah let me just
bring it up for you damn i like they
were probably like you people what the
hell
yeah [ __ ] damn wow i knew she was an
activist i didn't know this there she's
in vietnam on the other side
saying stop the war how do you like that
wow i didn't live this down for like two
decades really like the 80s into the
jazzercise stuff she didn't really live
it down
she married ted turner right that's
right damn i like how she does it she's
not just tweeting she's like i'll go
there and i'll sit on a plane
yeah
yeah the new jane fonda is just gonna be
like i retweeted something exactly
that's it hey man uh great lilly tomlin
movie steve martin all of me
you ever see that one no i don't know it
yeah it's a good flick lily tomlin is
great she's great so funny been funny
for years friends with prior
yeah he was in love with her is that
right yeah but she was she was gay big
less he's gay yeah
wait how old's uh fonda we never got it
born in 37 i can't do the math sounds
like 85.
wow i don't know anyone will do math
there beer jew 84. jane fonda is 84. so
we found mark's high number there you go
84. that's you know i would do it you
would oh yeah bring her a metamucil and
a nice nice plowing
yeah we'd have dinner at 4 p.m and uh
make love you get you get out for your
spots in time
yeah and she'd probably have a gimlet
[Laughter]
man these are these do go down pretty
easily they're too easy these old ladies
are onto something
it doesn't sound easy
ted turner huh he's uh the superstation
yeah yeah pbs tbs yeah
good for him
is he still alive no way right i think
so i think he also owned braves yeah he
did wow he's a big republican didn't he
oh yeah that was the whole thing i think
so what the hell she's all fighting the
vietnam war then she says he's still
alive born in 38. wow wow he's hanging
in there he was hitting that older woman
well they're the same age right she was
born in 37. there you go
everyone talks about power move dating
younger i think a real power move is
dating older
interesting who's done that ah i don't
know davidson
he has
a few times kate uh what's her name
beckinsale yeah
doesn't get much hotter than that good
for him pull her up just uh just to get
the needle moving
it's not the only thing moving
she's 48 44
i'll tell you i mean 40 is the new 30 or
whatever they say but uh it's true
well would you just like well for her
yeah true i love them i i've had that
thought where i'm like man i hope i age
like you know some of these actors and
you're like they look different at my
age yeah
you know you see like clooney now you're
like well maybe all ages like that
you're like look at clooney at 35. yeah
he looks [ __ ] good he's amazing full
head of hair
in shape good skin
nice suit on
we never see clooney in like a bathrobe
now although he'd probably have a nice
bathroom you'd probably look good in
that too yamaha how do you guys feel
about a bathrobe yeah do you like do you
guys own a bathrobe i don't but all the
things you've stolen it's never been a
bathrobe yeah i guess you're right i
never put it on it's not me
really well i'll throw it on at a hotel
or something but i you put one on you
just
i used to have that old joke a bathrobe
is the weirdest piece of clothing
because it's either a mental patient or
hugh hefner yeah you know there's not
much in the middle
yeah that's true you know it's it's
kingpin
and there weren't it for different
reasons yeah yeah hugh hefner's just
like i'm gonna [ __ ] every three hours
right that's why he's wearing the
you wear one
i have one i don't really wear it you
see i got it during the pandemic during
the pandemic you start buying [ __ ] you
don't really need oh yeah but you're
just like yeah [ __ ] i've never been on
etsy like i'll give you a shot oh you
had that nice one yeah it looks cool
looks great it's like a huge that's like
a hefner smoker's jacket totally it's a
badass see my dad wore this shitty blue
it looked like an old towel and it
scarred me because he crossed his legs
it was like basic instances
no underwear
huge balls
hairy it was wild you like wayne night
you're sweating but for a different
reason
yeah yeah he had black socks up to here
with the with the balls out
was basic instinct a good movie
i think it was pretty good for a
thriller
yeah i just remember jacking off to it
as a child so i don't remember if it was
like good or not but i remember like it
wasn't just sharon stone it was gene
triple horn too yes oh that's right
look at you bringing in the uh the b
squad well you got to remember if you
have a history
oh triple h was my jewish slur
that's right now i remember triple
i really am mark's jewish friend that
lets him get away with this [ __ ]
yeah like i'm like i wonder why mark
wants to do a podcast with me then he
says that i'm like ah all right
oh no i'm [ __ ] around the jewish
thing actually held me back
what's that guys what's the uh the
anti-defamation league
the the when you make a jewish joke they
come after you and they came up to che
for a while he did a jewish joke but
they're going to come after you for
letting me i don't think they'll even
touch me i remember chase joke i didn't
find it offensive i didn't either yeah
although we're not the right people but
also it's like we kind of are
right what was the joke i don't even it
was something about israel but it was
kind of like
you know what stereotype joke yeah who
gives a [ __ ] it's like one of the things
you're like
like maybe we're not the right people to
talk to offensive jokes because we don't
get offended that easily but also like
then maybe we are the right people
because it's what we do interesting like
we are decent at walking that line yeah
you got to walk the line
everybody's mad about something that's
the thing everybody goes i have a great
sense of humor blah blah but everybody's
uh a snowflake about one topic sure and
you kind of just like we'll just get
through this one and then we'll be fine
exactly i mean it's
these people that get offended you're
like well how many 911 jokes have you
landed
landed might be the wrong wrong word
but i hear you
that's a good point
well yeah but i mean you know they
they're like well these jokes are easy
and you're like yeah not really yeah i
did a show in philly last night it was
all white and there was one black guy
and i did a black joke and i was killing
and it got like oh
and the black guy was laughing yeah and
i was like was that joke okay sir he
goes as long as it's funny yeah which
was nice of him to do i think you got to
cut out the n-word but otherwise
otherwise it's a good job it was still
funny no
but yeah he was cool with it and uh it's
just weird because i don't know i have
this whole thing where we talk about
equality but i do a jew joke and it gets
a huge laugh like super anti-semitic
joke it's a laugh but the black jokes
get like
and i'm like what about equality
well i think those people would say the
jews had an easier time in america
that's what it is i think that's what it
is it wasn't here
i think that's i think that's what it
comes down to i said i was about to say
it was overseas but that sounds too
glamorous
that was overseas right
uh yeah you know uh i think that's what
it comes down to to people but also i'll
here's the other thing is i think
in private i think people are very
comfortable being anti-semitic in the
last couple years so i do think uh
that doesn't plays a role in it yeah i
think you're right and do you think
jokes help facilitate that
i think sometimes you're getting blood
laughs and you don't realize it what is
that i think that means that some people
are laughing for the right reason and
some people are laughing for the wrong
reason nice my opinion i don't know i
mean who knows i think most audiences
are smart enough to like i don't i think
very few people think that they're
racist or anti-semitic yeah you know i
think very few people will be like oh
yeah i'm racist you know yeah and even
the kkk is probably like nah i just you
know i prefer white people
they probably look at it like they don't
think they don't think it's like hateful
they're probably like yeah it's just how
i feel right right i prefer ice cream to
custard i don't hate custard for ice
cream but that's how they feel about you
know whites and blacks well they
probably they're probably that's like
the new like woke kkk guy he's in
therapy he's like no i just feel like i
don't like other races
how i feel yeah you can't tell me how to
feel you can't argue with my feelings
i remember mark did a show this is last
year and uh you were like how about them
jews and some guy yelled out [ __ ] them
oh yeah that was in philly
was it yeah and then they threw the guy
out and then mark saw him after the show
and got like i don't know why i said
that like i loved you it said my
girlfriend's jewish rover was jewish
isn't that fascinating he just went
there maybe he was just mad at his
girlfriend
it is weird like i remember like it is
it's that's the thing though it's like
when mark does a racial joke or i do a
joke that's like teetering on the edge
of something it is like a sign of trust
i don't know if you guys saw the penn
gillette article on bob saggett in the
new york times no he wrote a really
moving article about his friend like how
i guess his kids saw bob saget and they
were like
this guy's making pedophilia jokes
that's like not cool and ben gillette's
like
but he did it as like a sign of trust
with an audience like like the way he
told a joke like that it was because he
was being like
trust me trust you we can go here
together yeah so i think that's kind of
a nice way to talk about a joke like
that where you're like well this is a
sign of trust yes what is it about jokes
that bother people so much cause you can
do a movie about pedophilia or even a
documentary about pedophilia these are
real pedophiles and you're
watching them and and almost relating to
them because we're all looking for the
same response we're looking for a laugh
as like a movie they make a movie about
pedophilia people can be like well
that's disgusting ah maybe like he's
making art about how disgusting this is
right movie about slavery is different
because people are watching although do
we need any more slavery movies
i think we got it yeah i think we've got
i remember i saw 12 years a slave and i
went to the comedy cellar and we were
taught i was with like colin quinn and
keith robinson and uh and keith goes if
you see and i go oh yeah it was it was
great and he goes go [ __ ] yourself
he's like i don't want to hear a white
guy say it was great i was like all
right fair enough you gotta love keith
i went with two c 12 years later with a
black friend which is brutal by the way
and uh he's like you liking this and i
was like i kind of want to leave but i
feel like i can't he goes well now you
know how the slave show
it's like
i saw it in one of those movie theaters
where the seats recline
i've never felt more guilty in my life
you don't want to be comfortable for
that type of movie yeah yeah and you're
like are these seats cotton
uh yeah yeah so you think it's because
i'm making you're making a joke you're
making
humor out of this horrible thing instead
of just all agreeing it's horrible i
think the people that get upset like
here's the thing when people get upset
by a joke it's kind of like well
maybe that's good because it means that
people are taking stand up seriously as
an art form because that's what people
get upset by a lot of the times it's
like you know but at the same time like
do people get mad at like a de kooning
painting it's of a vagina clearly or
something you know or like do people get
mad about that [ __ ] but they get mad
about jokes they get mad about jokes yes
you see people get i guess people do get
mad at tarantino though yeah i think
people got mad at him for saying the n
word it was a weird scene that was a
weird scene yeah but i mean i love
tarantino i do too but also you can
you can look at a comedian and go [ __ ]
you tarantino there's a lot of layers
between you and him that's my point is
like
it's more
objective isn't the right word but it
kind of it can give it's a more
objective response for people yeah yeah
you can feed that i always saw it as
comics are out there giving their
opinion whether you think so or not
that's the way our viewers we look at
you it's like oh they're out there
telling us their philosophy and their
opinions and when someone tells a racist
joke you're like that's how you really
feel
even though it's not how you feel also
to go off what you're saying a character
versus like absolutely they buy that you
know when tarantino is saying that he's
playing a character right and if we were
to say something [ __ ] up they're like
well that's you know but it's a
heightened version of us obviously right
yeah
but also it's like yeah the pedophilia
is so horrific so horrible that
obviously i'm joking yeah you know it's
like when we say oh whatever you i just
made a black joke you're like well the
n-word was probably a bad idea and then
we all laugh because obviously i didn't
say the n word right so that's the weird
thing like the joke is how crazy it is
yeah you know that's like when bob
saget's like well i [ __ ] kids and
everybody laughs we all know okay he
probably doesn't that's why it's funny
yeah i mean it's like pedophilia it's
disgusting it's horrible it's the only
way i can get hard i mean it's
unacceptable you know that's exactly
that's comedy all right yeah but uh
yeah i mean
it's be i feel like we haven't all been
in a room in a minute it's kind of nice
very nice this has been i mean the thing
about covid right now is like we
probably all had it and we don't know it
but
um what sucks what sucks is that like
the symptoms are just being a jew
it's like upset stomach tired achy i'm
like this is how i feel every day in my
life playing retail
if the cdc throws up complaining
yes
i'm in deep [ __ ]
one of the symptoms is achy cold soup's
not warm
i'm like holy like did you just send
back your food you're like get a test
this is bad
yeah we went to a jewish deli not too
long ago and it felt like that like we
were like
some guy sat next to us and said he's
like we don't want to sit next to this
guy we're too close and it was we got
jewier yeah yeah it does make you
complain more yeah but also you feel
comfortable complaining at like a second
avenue deli or cat's a deli type because
you're like they've heard it all before
real exactly that's so true you're
amongst your people
they understand
can i give can i give a weird wreck
please because this is
so this is a wreck where like this is a
kind of a throwback wreck but like we
were spoiled like i guess matt like a
few years older than us but like we kind
of grew up on the same [ __ ] the 90s were
such we were so spoiled with comedy
movies oh yeah and you get movies now
there's not a lot of great comedy movies
more like hollywood won't green light
comedies really because i don't think it
really makes a lot of money though we
could do a comedy or we could do uh a
spin-off for every character in the
marvel universe we're good exactly you
know somebody's used to make money in
dvd sales
and now there are no dvd sales right so
they don't green light comedies much
anymore interesting well a lot of
comedies from the 90s blew up you're
right on vhs or d like austin powers i
don't think blew up in the theater i
think that was like a lot of those it's
word of mouth yeah so half big too
bombed in the theaters huge cult classic
amongst it i i had it too i bought it oh
yeah sagittarius
oh that's right i used to suck dick for
coke yeah classic also uh you know we
had like you know eddie murphy was like
in the 90s more 80s it really popped up
but he had some great 90s flicks but
then you got like sandler jim carrey
here's my wreck
we watch some chris tucker performances
cause that dude is he is one of the
funniest dudes oh yeah so he steals
everything he's in
steals and like all right so the good
thing about having a girlfriend that's a
little younger than you is you kind of
uh
she missed out on some of this [ __ ] so
i'm like all right so i tell taylor i'm
like why don't we watch
we're on vacation we just saw 22 jump
street on tv so i was like let's watch
rush hour yeah because you like these
types of movies like funny buddy you've
never seen rush hour it's fun and i feel
like that's a good
oh yeah but that's an easy way to get
someone into chris tucker's like the
mainstream one yeah and it's [ __ ]
hilarious dude jackie chan [ __ ] rules
rules they were such a great yin and
yang
not the movie
they were such a great you know pairing
that was so odd coupley and the cop
thing the buddy cop movie i mean it's
basically tre what is it called 48 hours
but with an asian guy yeah it's
brilliant oh dude you know what it is
too it's i remember by the way colin
quinn had a joke on weekend update back
in the day about uh tiger woods winning
uh
the pj tour and he was like tiger woods
wins the pga tour making him the best
black and asian combination since rush
hour
[Laughter]
cq
but uh it has the great combination of
action
like that kung fu kind of action [ __ ]
with black humor i mean that's great
it's it's so true chris takush so and
then you know what i love about the
movie too is the credits are hilarious
because it's them [ __ ] up is jackie
chan [ __ ] up a stunt you're like this
is insane yeah it's chris tucker just
continually [ __ ] up lines yeah
apparently he can't read well
and he does which one oh chris okay and
he doesn't study his lines which one do
you think chris jackie chan learned
another language
well that's what i thought i was like oh
you must be done by jackie chan
and so he doesn't study his lines and he
sort of just picks up line by line as he
goes
dude he's so he's so funny that's why
there's so many bloopers well he's going
to fish like the
filter
he kept going at filter fish
he's dude he's so funny in the movie and
and rush hour two is solid too and then
also dude money talks oh yeah friday
you know friday is good i mean he stole
friday friday's all him
[Music]
i know that movie so well but dude uh
money talks i was i was rereading i was
like let me i really just i'll reread uh
like roger ebert's reviews because he's
so his writing's so good
and he had a funny thing about he first
off he's like praising chris tucker he's
like look this movie makes no sense he's
like he talks about this one scene where
i guess these like russian uh these
russian terrorists want to break their
guy out of prison so they they make the
bus explode and he's like this makes no
sense because you're like this would
kill everyone yeah like how are you just
positive that your one guy would get out
they explode the boss and like the one
guy and chris tucker make it out right
so uh but like dude it's so funny
oh he's also in a fifth element he's
like a crazy character in fifth element
jackie brown too that's right that's
right he i mean friday he kind of had
like a breakout because he was a comic
and then they put him in friday and he
was equally as funny he still has the
best michael jackson def jam performance
because everybody did michael jackson it
was like a staple with the def jam guys
and he has the best one
he kills that there's a scene in rush
hour too where he's doing karaoke as he
sees a guy butchering michael jackson so
he just starts he's like he's like oh
come on and it just cuts and like of
course jackie chan's like keep a low
profile there are triads here and he's
like you got it next thing he's like
and everyone everyone's waiting this is
this is too new you got to go go to the
go to the rush hour too chris tucker
doing karaoke because he does the
michael jackson
i love when a guy does a good bit so
they just shoehorn it into the movie
that's not it that's all that's newer
you can go to he's doing michael when
he's singing and he's doing the dance
his dancing is hilarious oh yeah so
funny he's just this wiry dude yeah it
is funny when people get money because
in the second rush hour like i should
he's kind of ripped now oh yeah
[Music]
you know it's cool till he starts saying
the words that's when it sounds crazy
you see me in the club with a pilot for
the buzzer
don't don't sing the words please i love
that song
that's a good impression
i love it
that is a cold-blooded beat you gotta go
to his old
i'm talking about go go rush hour to
karaoke that's that's okay
are you doubting me no no it's i can't
spell karaoke oh they'll fill it in for
you okay it's kkk
one of these look good to you i don't
know i can't see it so far away
speaking of uh blooper reels i just
rewatched uh life with eddie murphy and
martin lawrence good movie good movie
but at the end they do the credit needed
blooper reels and eddie murphy is
zinging and riffing during the the
people [ __ ] up and you're like this
guy is he's already so funny in the
movie but he's on another level yeah
it's fun you can see a guy be funny in
the moment the ending was so great too
at the yankee game oh yeah
[Laughter]
dude
[Music]
come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh he really commits so good so good
he's like there's there was always uh i
went to public school i grew up with
guys like that and you could just hear
the black girls going he crazy
i love him dude i was i remember seeing
money talks i think three times in the
movie theater whoa i loved you you were
the only one
i mean he was great with charlie sheen
too they had a good sheen is an
underrated comedy actor oh yeah i mean
hot shots come on great two and a half
men is like one of the biggest sitcoms
of all time that's true yeah also spin
city he's great i don't remember him he
took over from michael j fox
i thought he was great on it
that's a great cast it's like oh yeah
alan ross
and uh richard kind yes
great cass heather locklear oh yeah
she had a run
that was back that was when sitcoms were
just starting to kind of go away you
know i was like the last hurrah that
whole spin city era
what uh what do you got for a wreck i
got a weird one i'm going the other way
hit me all right all right so
went down to texas
and i'm i got bumped up to first class
highlight of my life
shane gillis is sitting next to me he's
pounding drinks because he's a psycho
it's like 12 30 in the afternoon so i go
all right i think it's 12 45 here by the
way oh
[ __ ] well he's already had a few at the
bar or whatever sure and he's like yeah
we're going to text like you know what
[ __ ] give me it's free drinks in
first class so we're talking about
movies because we're going through the
the movie thing the menu and he's like
you got to watch this and i was in the
mood for a western maybe i was going to
texas i had a whiskey in my hand so he
goes put this on and i was like all
right
old henry what's that incredible such a
great movie so fun
i was half in the bag by the end of it
but uh it's brand new
it's the guy from um
[Music]
oh what's his name he's got a weird name
he's the guy from uh oh brother where
art though oh tim blake nelson that's it
yeah he's the whole movie and it's him
and his son living out on the range and
you know problems arise and he's got to
handle it it's incredible
and a lot of these questions can be slow
this is action-packed it's incredible
it's emotional
he's a great actor so good yeah great
actor great who directed it and who
wrote it that's a great question we have
here you gotta remember i was in a
bourbon haze at uh ten thousand feet
that's uh
i have a bigger question
did joe rogan fly you down first class
he put us up in the four seasons so
that's a no how'd you get first class i
got bumped up it was an empty place wow
yeah delta baby i'm trying to stay loyal
stay loyal yes well
you ain't loyal don't you feel like uh
westerns have kind of made a comeback
i do and i have a theory about that
what's your theory stop if i've told you
this because again we drink a lot easy
beard you worry all right well if you're
uh if you're over here might as well
touch that puppy we might be drunk is
excited to announce our new sponsor
indochino
tire looking like a schlub indochino is
here to get you looking and feeling like
a man about town in 2022
i just got some pants from there there's
some nice chinos navy
beautiful fit like a glove indochino is
good because they get your real sizes
your real measurements they go all in
they want to know exactly how you're
tailored you don't need to go to the
tailor you don't need to get the guy to
go up your your crotch there and tell
you hang to the left i already knew that
thank you for touching my genitals
indochino does it all online they send
you some good stuff it's quality offers
completely custom fitted suits shirts
casual wear and more surprisingly at
affordable prices every piece is made to
your exact measurement and you can
customize every detail all online that's
what i'm saying
choose everything about your suit
including the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings you can create a suit
that fits you and your style perfectly
the best part indochino suits start from
429 and shirts from 79 with all
customizations included that's a great
deal tell them how to get on it fatty
give yourself a style that sets the tone
for the rest of your year within doshino
i'm drunk get 50 off of every purchase
of 399 or more by using promo code drunk
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 399 or more that's nice indochino.com
that's n-i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot-com promo code drunk support the
show you get 50 off any purchase of 399
or more by using promo code drunk at
indochino.com that's already a pretty
good deal hell of a deal we're getting
you a better deal yeah support the show
supporting doshino guys here here what's
your theory i think we're all so
obsessed with our phones we're also up
our own asses with social media and the
news all these westerns they're out
alone on a range they gotta they're
living off the land it's killing cattle
it's riding horses it's sunshine it's
farming the till in the field
it's like an escape
we need a little bit of uh sunshine a
little bit outdoors a little bit of uh
nature and
and uh simplicity i completely agree
i can and it's like we're watching it on
our phones yes but there but we're still
like oh that's cool yeah it brings us
back to our roots i mean this is old
americana [ __ ] they're in like oklahoma
and 17 whatever 1819 or whatever it is
and it appeals to everyone because you
live in that kind of life you're like
well this is like is relatable to me but
like to me
as a new yorker in a tiny apartment yeah
that open range looks pretty cool i know
i know and there's you know problems
occur and you have problems in your life
and it's still relatable even though
you know that we were miles apart
technology-wise
so true i mean it's
great point i also think there's
something about people feel like they've
lost so much
you know in this pandemic and everything
that
your land your space like there's
something to that too interesting i
don't know i like that i like that but
it's a real minimalist lifestyle and i
think yeah we kind of crave that a
little bit
yeah we all want to feel like we've uh
like we've
we still have that in some way we don't
i mean there's this hit show now yellow
jackets on show time and uh he's a fan i
like it it's campy as hell yeah but i
like it i love that
i love her she's so funny on it great
but um and a forehead like a drive-in
movie theater but hell of an actress
does she oh my god pull up that i don't
know if we have a big enough tv for that
uh that noggin on old reach
oh reach
look at that thing holy hell you could
uh you could watch blazing saddles on
that thing oh i think it's pretty
standard well she knows what she's doing
with those bangs i'll tell you that but
uh you get a hair pull back and look i'm
very attracted to her she's got a good
look
hot lady but look at that one come on
that thing's about a five incher that's
a five head where i come from
all right we'll keep it moving i don't
want to get it there's like a hot
hollywood actress and marcus like look
at that head
i respect the brains
[Laughter]
um no she's great on it and dude but you
know what it is it's like all the women
on the show are so [ __ ] up from the
from the island and i think we all feel
like these are the shows that take off
now it's like we all feel mentally
[ __ ]
from this pandemic
totally i mean you know what pisses me
off so much right now is i don't know if
you like you're you're another like
native new yorker so like i know you
think of mayor adams so far oh he's
trump he's like he's trump isn't that
right he's hiring his brother who was
like a parking lot attendant to be like
the top cop
well he's getting a ton of [ __ ] now
because an asian woman was pushed to her
death in front of a train at times
square 9 30 in the morning insane and
mayor adams uh just goes well you know
uh
only like one point something percent of
crime actually takes place on the subway
it's you know it's people's perception
i'm like really it's our perception that
i just i'm just perceiving uh a bunch of
[ __ ] on every subway line that i'm
seeing now like right
i've been riding the train something's
off am i wrong something's up it's all
right something's up i think there's
less policing and there's just more
wackos on the train now it's a winter
and less regular people it's the winter
yeah people keep going crazier and
crazier from this pandemic in this city
and then you throw in 10 degree weather
right what do you think's gonna happen
this [ __ ] is this is lord of the flies
on the train he was a cop you think he
would go hardcore on the policing he's
got so much to worry about right now i
mean there's so much [ __ ] going on but
you got to be better on the subway this
is new york we need the subway
but dude i'll tell you like i used to do
most of my writing on the train like i
would just kind of
space i would sit in the train i'd space
out and i just kind of wander and find
jokes you can't do that anymore because
you're too worried about there's too
many weirdos on the train and you've got
to keep your guard up just in case but
oh man i've seen dude with no pants the
other day like go to the next train i
see i used to have a joke about where
you see a crazy person they're trying
sugar the next subway car and you see an
even crazier person right i think i
traded down here but uh but that's like
what it is right now in the subways
i guess you don't take it as much
because you walk to a lot of space but i
took it here i took it all last night
but it's really interesting night is
when it gets shady yeah i haven't
carried a knife since i was a teenager
i'm on amazon looking for knives get the
hell out of here you're a knife guy i
think so whoa you can hold it this way
too like
yeah
i'm gonna keep it in the boot where you
keep it uh you can keep it on your hip
as long as it's under four inches and it
doesn't it's not a gravity blade which
means it doesn't go like this
click open
it's legal wow all right under four
inches and i can jump out
it was coming i was gonna bounce on it
but i knew he was [ __ ] grabbing it
all right also mary adams just like if
you don't harm someone with it uh
illegal possession of weapon is not
really illegal anymore oh really as long
as you don't use it in a harmful manner
that's true you can just keep a firearm
yeah that's why i just hold a gun out
and i go come at me [ __ ] and fire it
yeah
interesting well i gotta say this is
gonna get dicey but i think a lot of
people voted for him like he's a black
guy he's a cop this will be good and
then i don't think people really like
listened to him or read up on him i
think they're like oh you know we need a
black guy he's a skill politician too he
knows he knows how to i mean also no one
good ever runs for mayor that's the
other problem is like no one ever is
like no we never get a good mayor
it's kind of impressive well you had
koch
people seem to like that guy they didn't
like him when he was mayor yeah he was
why he would always say how am i doing
that was his catchphrase how am i doing
he knew it wasn't that good and then
giuliani did some good no he only liked
him after 9 11.
he actually cleaned up new york prior to
9 11 as i recall like the broken windows
thing yeah like he like policed he was a
prosecutor yeah got rid of the subways
he got you got he cleaned up the subway
yeah his biggest thing is that like he
made subways safe giuliani giuliani was
like he was like harvey dent and batman
right cause he was like that lawyer
that's like i fear no one and you're
like yeah but shit's gonna turn for you
dude
his son is now trying to make a run at
it do you see this sheriff's man
embarrassed he's he's like a baby trump
too yeah wow
man
i don't watch the news at all but i
heard a lot of [ __ ] about a
lot of lib or democrats are jumping ship
to republican is that true oh why just
because they're like i'm sick of it i'm
out i'm going repub well i get why
people who like if you're in the
restaurant business i get why you're fed
up with like oh yeah if you're like
when you're bailing out like airlines
and you're bailing out hotels but then
like mom and pop restaurants are getting
like [ __ ] maybe a ppp loan or
something it's like
i get why you're kind of like what are
you doing for me yeah yeah things have
really flipped because it used to be all
about mom and pop and now it's like
corporations are killing it and then
big pharma is killing it with pfizer so
it's like kind of gone the other way now
we used to be like [ __ ] these big
farmers [ __ ] these corporations and now
it's like hey amazon i need my package
and hey give me the vaccine
the amazon vaccine is going to be the
best
that's going to be a good vaccine we'll
get there overnight
i want the prime
[Laughter]
um it's funny you order these masks now
online and they're like there could be a
counterfeit and you're like you get the
masking like [ __ ] n94
[ __ ]
i got this [ __ ] fake mask
damn yeah it's a weird time to be alive
any do you have any wrecks matt
um
yes station eleven oh i'm gonna watch
you i'm enjoying it you're liking it
okay i'm like how far are you in i'm
only three episodes in but i'm hooked i
think it's like too smart for me really
what do you mean i i think they're
following some like four or five
shakespearean plays i think and like i
only know two of them
yeah and like i'm missing some of the i
wish i was smarter to enjoy it more but
i really loved it
even if you don't get the shakespeare
though it's still it's still solid yeah
i gotta watch it it's the same director
who did atlanta hero or something
yeah
i gotta go back to atlanta oh yeah i
only did the first season third season
is masterpieces really incredible yeah
man that donald glover he's too talented
yeah he's a good looking guy he's a good
comic he's a good rapper he's a good
actor and he can write he wrote a couple
30 rocks he wrote a couple community
apps he's killer yeah he's kind of got
it all right yeah he did that this is
america thing
that went viral that was cool huge and
he's a nice guy i used to i used to know
him before he was huge yeah i remember
you used to pop it on cabin that yeah
isn't that weird yeah he had some great
jokes too he had he was he was so scared
of having a kid he had this great joke
he's like uh
he's like uh i think i'd rather have
aids than have a kid my uncle's got
five kids he looks like he has eights ah
something like that
that's fun he's good does the guy like
that change does he fundamentally change
like if he saw you would he treat you
differently no i think he's just so busy
i think he'd be like oh hey what's up i
think he's a cool guy i think he's down
earth i mean he's got the craziest
backstory grew up in a foster home with
a bunch of
his mom adopted a bunch of hiv kids so
then he would be like mom
you didn't give my lunch money she would
rather have aids and kids yeah
yeah but then he'd be like i couldn't
complain cause the other kids had aids
so like how could i be like ah
this is not enough pancakes or whatever
damn
yeah he had a crazy upbringing so he's
just like
beating in down earth guy
he's not changing interesting cool dude
yeah i don't i don't remember talking to
him ever but i remember he'd be we'd be
on the same show sometimes and he seemed
he seemed like
cool and down to earth i don't know very
nice very nice good egg now what about a
peeve
i get a few let me see what i like oh
i haven't seen in a minute so i've been
just jotting peeves down all week kind
of fun would do something with this it
is
otherwise just annoyed
how about this one
the guy
who shits on something uh
because
he won't do it all right here is an
example i go uh hey i just got city bike
and i'm not gonna say who but my friend
was like
oh yes
yeah yeah it's good you should you
should ride a bike every now and then
he's like yeah but aren't a lot of those
electric
and i'm like yeah there are they are but
it's still better than nothing he goes
i'm not riding an electric bike
i'm like but you burn calories still and
he's like nah it's electric
so i'm like you won't do it because it's
electric but it's still better than not
doing it at all
you see what i'm saying yeah i hate that
mentality of like i'm not doing that
they're electric they don't they barely
do anything i'm like but you're now
you're doing nothing you're still moving
your legs a little right yes yeah it's
like i think the peeve here is
unnecessarily [ __ ] on your point
like you're not even taking this
anywhere else right you didn't need to
[ __ ] on the point yes
and now you're you're still at
that guy yeah and he's like i'm trying
he's basically he's trying to lose
weight and i'm like you should do city
bike he's like those are electric i'm
not doing that i'm like
but it's still now you're doing zero
you see you're still fat as [ __ ] and you
could ride the bike but you won't
because they're electric doesn't make
sense they're not all electrical and
they're not all electric yeah but that
was his move like to get out of it like
oh well some are electric i'm like okay
well now you just stay
you know a lazy bastard so i'm not gonna
take a flight why some of them get
canceled right exactly
it's a horrible way to shut it down but
he was like nah they're electric and in
his mind that was some some winning
argument to like not ride a bike
interesting yeah crazy do you get what
i'm saying you see it all right i mean
i'm useless i can't really ride a bike i
try i remember during like the beginning
of the pandemic when we we didn't know
if covert could be like transmitted
outdoors or anything or whatever i'll
ride a bike down at the cellar i wiped
out like three times yeah
i suck yeah oh man i know i remember my
dad taught me to ride a bike for like
two hours
and i think one of the times we were in
central park and i just went down a hill
without him and crashed right into a
tree and flew off and he was like he's
not a bike rider
that was it damn another worse wipe it
out in new york cause someone's gonna
see it
yeah and it's also just like
you're like what are you this is i don't
need a bike around here
i'll work on other [ __ ]
the biking has gone up
ten thousand percent in this city i hate
it because now when you try to bike down
like the west side highway there's like
80 bikes they're weaving around like
what is this formula one i didn't think
i know it's a guy on a full on the this
the spandex with the helmet that's
aerodynamic he's like left
like jesus christ feels like mario kart
he just throws a [ __ ] shell and
you're like ah yeah right you throw a
banana peel behind you i know it's crazy
these guys are all in i think they're
sober or maybe impotent they get the
bike with the skinny tires
i think these guys need something to do
they need something yeah skinny tires
piss me off although the fat tires don't
really make sense either here's a peeve
i got all right i was talking to a guy
and he was like it was like a comedy
booker and he's like if you're late for
some un for unexpl for uh sorry if
you're late for an inexplicable reason
and i was like what do you mean
inexplicable
like i can't explain why i'm late ghosts
why were you late uh the middle east i
can't
i can't explain it right
that's true yeah that's a weird i don't
like when people say that it's like like
do you have no reason to be late should
things get delayed yeah things have i
mean what do you mean you have no reason
that that is annoying
i told him my lady does that i'll be
like she'll be like where are you i'm
like the flight was delayed she's like
ah you're always uh you're always late
i'm like the flight was delayed like
it's not me it's the flight
you're waking up in a hotel room with a
switchblade and math you're like it's
the flight
i think that was a geraldo bit he was
like he was like you wake up with a
switchblade and you [ __ ]
it was a flight was like six weeks ago
and it just just rolled up
um
yeah inexplicable that's funny
and explain what is inexplicable mean
everything can be explained
oh yeah
that's true even if you don't know
you're like well i can't explain it but
yeah i don't know for for being late you
can explain it
inexplicable
i'm smelling it wrong
oh that's the movie ah
there it is i've seen that movie how the
[ __ ] did this get made it's inexplicable
[Laughter]
enabled good good excuse for having low
ratings we don't know we have no idea
what
matt do you have a peeve
me yeah oh i wasn't prepared oh
yeah oh you're always upset about
something
you know what's pissing me off and i
don't know maybe i'm just a [ __ ] guzzler
here but i hate the key card in the
elevator
i hate pulling the key card out twice to
get the hotel what's the purpose is it
for security it's a security yeah so you
just can't go up so i get it i'm okay
with it but i'm annoyed like oh i gotta
to move the
elevator and then you have that person
who gets in yeah and they're just like
can you do it again you're like why
don't you do it i know now i'm doing it
three times
exactly
when you do it and it works for your
thing but not for theirs
that's [ __ ] oh that happens all the
time yeah yeah
okay i've got to pee hit me getting up
to your hotel room
after all the like rigmarole getting
your bags up there hitting the [ __ ]
key card doesn't open the door oh story
you have to go back down well the worst
is when you're in one of those like
airport hotels and they're like
800 rooms in there so you're walking
down a maze something like a giant area
and you're like how do i remember i was
high as [ __ ] once in seattle
and uh it was a classic situation where
they want to put you up in like this i
remember like you know when you're like
an abused puppy dog young comic and
you're like oh this is a cool uh motel
yeah like like i remember i say this in
this [ __ ] it was a motel it was like
you know uh and i was i was a young
comic so i was like there's a pancake
house next door this is amazing
but i remember marina franklin our
friend uh
stayed there and she called me she's
like did you stay here and i'm like yeah
she's like this is like sketchy and then
as she said that i was like oh yeah
there was a heroin addict who fell
asleep against my uh my window
he like passed out against my window and
i just like opened it he was like mushed
into the window like wow but i didn't i
wasn't that i was like man it's
different experience and for a woman so
but even then i was like that's kind of
weird yeah i was watching forensic files
and every room looked like the one i was
staying into but it was like one of
those things where you're like ah
whatever but then when she said that
they oh yeah and then the next time i
was there i
asked oh can i not stay in that hotel
again and the guy wrote back to my agent
pass in all caps like he won't book me
damn
and then i was like all right i guess
that's how it goes and then uh and then
you go back all right we'll have him and
they put me and they put me in this
hotel but like he made it a point to
like drive me back drunk every night
and then i was in that hotel and that
kept happening i i
took an edible or something and i was
[ __ ] up and i don't know like well i
kept
trying to get in the room i'm like i'm
freaking out like what the hell it was
like a maze the hotel terrible
and you're the junkie leaning on the
window in the next scene yeah yeah it
became you
it came full circle it's funny with the
drive back to the hotel a lot of these
uh
comedy club owners think they're so nice
and i'm like i'd rather uber because
then i don't have to like chit chat with
you about ah
also like i'm worried you're gonna get
pulled over for a dui and then i'm after
uber anyway i think i know this owner
i think i know this guy but yeah i uh i
had a show in philly the other night
and a bunch of comics were driving there
who i didn't know and i was like i'm
gonna pay the 50 and take an amtrak i
had a great ride it was awesome and then
i got to the show and i rode back with
them and i'm like this is nice because
it was only one ride with them but two
would have been a lot two's a lot
it's nice to get work done that's and
that's also a [ __ ] business expense
like you write that up yeah good point
yeah dude i love the one-way ride
because you ride back you relax but on
the way to a show i like to i like to go
over notes i like to prep a little bit
oh yeah i'm a big backseat guy everybody
wants shotgun i hate shotgun too much
pressure up there you gotta [ __ ] with
the radio you gotta help navigate you
gotta you gotta respond to the driver to
my backseat i'm cruising shotgun doesn't
even sound good no
i got the shotgun you're like all right
i'll sleep in the back exactly you worry
about killing people behind us is that
why it's called shotgun what is it i i
think back in the old days yeah you got
a shoot out of the driver and the guy
next to you the stagecoach was
shotgunned we can probably update that
one i don't think a lot of people are
doing that anymore right i think it's
more likely that you're uh you're like
chatty
i'm radio
charge
phone charger yeah that's true dj where
you gotta go where you guys at with like
the balance of chit chat in the green
room
well if it's a guy i know or a gal i
like you know let's let's chat but
sometimes but like do you need time for
like i need time for myself here i like
to go over notes but like also you know
i usually bring a friend on the road so
they kind of we kind of usually have the
same uh
routine yeah yeah exactly i'm fine with
talking if there's a real convo but
small talk in the groom i'm like whoa
whoa this is the green room i don't need
to hear about uh your your dying aunt
you know
i just found out my my aunt is dying i'm
going over jokes yeah
but you know i don't want to be like
somebody's like hey how about this
omicron i'm like all right all right
with the small talk but if you've got a
good thing let's talk exactly small talk
no but like talk yeah small talk is for
people you don't even i mean like i do
have that like i'm very in my head i
think i know mark is like we're both
very in our heads so
me personally i feel smothered by
you guys it's easy because we kind of
just know each other but certain
conversations i feel like kind of
smothered or suffocated because i i'm so
in my head and it's tough because the
head is like this is like your channel
yeah my head is like it's trying to keep
me in my head it's like sports center
highlights soprano scenes fun memories
then someone else talks about the
weather and you're like yeah it's a
worse show
right who put this on
because i was at mark's taping for what
was your one called it was called out to
lunch another one before that
oh uh comedy don't be yourself don't be
yourself i was at that one taking
pictures
my manager was
yeah and uh we're all back there and
we're having a good time talking and
your producer walks in amy schumer and
she's like
clear the room oh yeah and i was like uh
does she mean me you know like because
there was a lot of riff-raff yeah but i
was like i'm taking pictures i'm working
for the show and like i'm a pal too
and so i just sat there she was like you
too and i was like oh
and she was like mark's trying to be
nice everyone get out
she knows me well well she's she was
good like that she did that to me too
when amy produced my comedy central
special as well uh shout out to amy
schumer man produce both our [ __ ]
specials we would not have had comedy
central hours without yeah right so amy
you're here to amy you [ __ ] rule also
her new movie the humans is great oh
yeah richard jenkins is in it he was one
of my favorite actors amy's grading it
uh beanie fieldstein i forgot the name
of the woman who plays a mother but
she's incredible it's it's a it's a play
as a movie it's it's it's a slow burn i
dug it but she's a great actor she
doesn't get her due for her acting i
mean she's working she's working but i
mean she's i think everyone thinks she's
a great actor okay she's got like a she
won a peabody
oh she did yeah inside amy schumer oh
yeah yeah she's like the biggest female
comedy actress i think she gets her dude
all right all right no but killer actor
she's amazing she's great at drama and
comedy but she uh she made me think she
liked me for years
[Laughter]
but she i remember my manager at the
time tried to get in the room and she
goes get out
i love it i well we don't have that
because like i'm too nice or i don't
want to hurt anybody but like i was in a
few green rooms with her where there was
some some weirdo in there and she'd be
like can i have the green room and it
wasn't that big of a deal but i was like
i could never do that and i would learn
from her
she also had uh someone make everyone in
the green room because afterwards it was
like you devito
uh
you know joe rachel
yeah ari rachel
feinstein and and she had someone make
us all manhattans in the green room so
the second i get off stage for my late
show we're all drinking good bourbon
good manhattans with the maraschino
cherry hell yeah i was like hell yeah
dude she knows what she's doing yeah so
did we go out after that was there an
after party yeah it was a brooklyn bar
oh yeah that's right
a lot a lot of familiar faces our buddy
scott rogowski yes that's right from hq
trivia mm-hmm our boy
fun night
yeah we've done so much that like that
was like a huge night but now tonight
was awesome i mean you shot that in that
temple that was awesome yes the angel or
zanz which is like a jewish temple from
the 18 whatever i'll tell you this guy's
dying to be one of us that's ryan i'm
trying to get in
he got circumcised right before the show
too i mean it was crazy i know can i get
some ice
but yeah um
great time great time those specials
that was like when tv was still tv
i mean i don't think anyone watched mine
mine either
those are the glory days when when uh
300 thousand people watch the special
yes exactly good days exactly now it's
what 125. that's like a bad tick tock
three hundred thousand and our clips
have done better than the actual tv show
we shot your special we were gonna air
it but office reruns do way better so
we're gonna cancel we're gonna play uh
she's one of the guys
should we do a bed yes now i got a weird
one here hit me
so i got a bit
that i think is is kind of stands on its
own but
i got that little dick in the back of my
head [ __ ] me going well is this too
close to sam's bed you shouldn't want to
buy them it may all right so i think
it's different but i do want to run it
by you so
i noticed that when you flip through
hbo max there's a lot of like categories
you know like trans stories or strong
black women or
asian culture you know they're trying to
be like progressive but i'm like hey hbo
i know you're trying to be progressive
but porn's been doing this for like 20
years ooh that's good i've been watching
asian culture since i was in high school
you know yeah
i don't know i don't think that's one of
them well you had that thing about porn
like bbw
uh you're fine facial
that's a great bit i rewatched a bit
totally to make
porn is more progressive than women's
magazines because there's fat and old
porn there's no fatty old women's that's
good magazines right there's you know
porn it's like you're not fat you're a
big beautiful woman
you're not old you're mature
you're not covered in semen you're
getting a facial that was a bit great
bit every woman where was that how to
shed light
i never saw it
but the clips done well adriana chechick
the porn star shared it on social media
oh
[Music]
that's huge um
what uh so my bit is just like i love it
and i love it it's calling out like you
think you're being progressive porn has
got you beat porn i think porn has been
doing this for years i think it's a
different bit porn's been putting trans
people on screen
way longer than any network you know
like way longer you got a francis
mcdormand movie uh is there a
penetration
[Laughter]
so and then the big close is like the
only difference is uh hbo the kids
section is a lot easier to find
is that too dark it's dark all right i
like it yeah it's funny
well you know they have like kids they
have cartoons but porn
you gotta do some digging yeah
apparently there's something
or maybe i was researching a bit yeah
yeah
or maybe you could do it something like
uh the kids
uh in hbo is right there
for uh porn it's barely kids
you know like barely legal right yeah
there's no barely kid section they call
it young adult right right
something about barely
pedo jokes are tough they're tricky
because you want it to be
clean which is a funny word to use to
describe that but yeah i mean like you
want it to just well the bit's hitting
except i need an ending so the kid thing
is a little like groany
but yeah
yeah like uh they've been doing this for
years porn's been doing this for years
yeah i think it's a different bit all
right just check i mean [ __ ]
everything's been done have you ever had
to give up a bit
oh because it was too similar sure twice
in like the last month it's brutal it's
like you just have to do it well i our
buddy ian finance had a similar uh joke
to me and like i love you and he's my
boy so it's like you just gotta it sucks
but it's like can you ask him be like
just too similar like like mark just did
um you know the setups for the jokes are
different but we use pretty much the
same words for the punch line so i just
i can keep the premise because it's
different from his joke but i need a new
punch line and
it's tough when you find the perfect
line because it's kind of like it's the
perfect line for a reason and jokes are
hard to crack so i just have to
figure it out but like you gotta if a
[ __ ] similar you gotta drop it without
that [ __ ] like there's no honor right
yeah and you're a good guy because
you're
i don't wanna be mean but you're bigger
than ian so like he could potentially
have to draw because you could just do
it but there's nothing to do if it's his
joke first it's like it's his joke first
i know but i'm sure if i had the same
joke as chris rock he'd be like i'll be
all right you know like he could still
do it well you're not friends with chris
rock that's true you know like ian's my
buddy i mean
uh it happens all the time like i've
been tough because you legitimately got
there yourself and then you heard it
later of course i didn't know his bit i
mean it's what happens i mean you know
mark and i have done this to each other
where like when you hang out with
someone all the time
sometimes you're like you come to the
same bit it happens like you joke around
together and then you both try a bit
about it
and then you kind of like oh [ __ ] we
kind of have to figure out who that is
or like you know i've had like i've text
mark bits and mark's like oh i have a
joke just like that that i ran by you
and it like seeps into your subconscious
it's possible it happens to everybody
it's unavoidable
so you just that's why you have to
really
i ask people to watch my special before
i put it out because i just want to make
sure i'm like have you heard anything
like this have you heard anything like
this because you just you're gonna it's
gonna happen to everyone by accident
because everything's been done does that
make you more sympathetic to joke
thieves
well i think like you know there's
there's consistent joke thieves and
there's accidents i think yeah and i
think you develop a reputation based on
whichever one
you are exactly yeah yeah there's
subconscious parallel thinking and then
there's thievery we put out a lot of
bits mark and i and that's like when you
write a lot of new jokes you're just
gonna run into it it just happened so
you just gotta be as careful as you can
i had a
similar joke to michael che and i just
dropped it because i don't know who
thought of it first
but
he's gonna have a netflix hour and i was
gonna do a youtube so i just dropped it
because he's bigger yeah but also
that was a joke about like we had a
black president but statistically we've
had a gay one
you know just because i remember that's
been 48 president whatever 45.
so you think statistically it's got to
be a gay one in there and that was
pretty pretty much the joke and uh he
had the same exact premise so i just i
think it's fdr that guy couldn't even
stand
he got all that that anal
he had a funny angle he was like i think
it's lincoln because he was at the
theater
that's good so i was like all right
that's probably a little more fleshed
out than mine so i just dropped it
yeah it's interesting yeah mark give a
bit
uh well that was that was my bit also
but i have another one but oh you you go
you meant sam game
let me see what i got i have a couple
ideas here um
let me see what i got
um
tell you let's go on it with the netflix
half hour out i've been trying to just
go cold
speaking of bits while you're looking i
had a bit i have like a six minute bit
it's like a staple in my act new bit
newish
and i did the charlotte
comedy zone and my opener did the same
[ __ ] bit same idea not stealing just
completely parallel thinking and i'm
like i guess i gotta drop it
you dropped it because of your opener
and charlotte well he did it on a dry
bar so it's already out there
so
we talked about it he's like yeah sorry
man that's like a five-year-old bit i
did on a dry bar and i was like all
right i guess that's over and it was
like a big bit in my act it's like a
staple happens to all of us i mean
that's why it's so hard to put out a lot
of specials because
i mean i saw a guy do one of my bits and
i'm like i don't think he stole it i
think it's just [ __ ]
it's like an old bit of mine i just
don't want people to think i stole
that's where i kind of like as long as
you don't think i stole it i don't give
a [ __ ] if someone else does a bit
because it's like it's going to happen i
mean i use so much due diligence so i
don't think anyone ever accuse you of
stealing something i think you try i do
so much people people always accuse you
i mean people are [ __ ] idiots but i
mean i the joke that i saw someone stole
mine i mean just not steal like did uh
was like i used to i did a joke on like
my album class act like 2015 but i also
did it on a conan and said i can't
believe i got on conan god bless conan
for letting us do this [ __ ] but i said
my friend's like i told my friend i'm
going on a date he goes you gotta you
gotta masturbate before the day because
that way if you get laid you last long
and i go here's what they don't tell you
if you masturb uh masturbate before a
date you're canceling the date
i said i call the girl up and i say
there's been a change of plans ah so
that was that joke
great like late night joke killed and
i'm like man i heard someone else do
it's like also like guess what another
guy can arrive upon that sure that's not
like it's not like i [ __ ]
did like a personal joke in my childhood
it's an observational funny joke yeah
yeah but uh i wonder if women can do
that they like
look through a wedding magazine they're
like ah i don't need a boyfriend
[Laughter]
they if they can come to that same
conclusion i think they definitely come
to that magazine but uh
here's uh here's my idea i saw a
headline by the way i do new jokes last
night at the cellar with the new joke
show
louie's in the room watching my set i'm
like i'm doing jokes i wrote today
this is [ __ ] excruciating to have one
of the best comics of all time just
being like
i know
i'm like new york i like i like doing
new jokes on the road where it's kind of
like yeah i can fail and bring it back
in an hour say you you've earned enough
goodwill in like 45 minutes but was he
going on or was he just there he went
out right before me and then he just
hung out after my set and i'm just kind
of like ah that is a head [ __ ] yeah he
was nice afterwards but you're also kind
of like i made a joke i'm like [ __ ]
louie
i was like someone said like lou you
have to follow louie i'm like i know
it's not fun yeah it's not fun uh
but you know louie's always got funny
[ __ ] what a city i say so i saw a
headline uh snow white under fire for
the kiss without consent
and i go literally like people were mad
about that scene i'm like literally a
movie from the late 1930s the same uh
10-year period of the of the holocaust
and people were like this is the thing
we need to revisit
this we need to take another look at
snow white yeah
what about the 8th dwarf jewie
and then i say like
i don't think the movie has inspired a
rape
right i don't think anyone's like i
don't think a college kid saw a woman
passed out at a party and was like snow
white dude nah see if she's a princess
yeah is that is it a princess no that's
what is it prince charming yeah i guess
sir
wake her up everybody was a princess
back then
every disney movie well the line i said
it needs more but i was like you know
like a judge is like they're like yeah
kid watched snow white you never had a
chance you know or something like
there's something about like no one's
raped
over disney right what about this angle
like she has to eat an apple why isn't
or why aren't we thinner you know that's
not promoting uh healthy eating
yeah i watched you know i watched snow
white as a kid i've never once eaten an
apple yeah
yeah exactly
also she lived in a house with with
seven dudes
isn't that weirder
yeah yeah it's like guess what uh
like hey i think you should never uh you
should never kiss a pass that woman
unless she lives in a house with seven
uh dwarfs in which case
it's a sign you know
something like that or something yeah so
a prince kissed her when she was asleep
was that what happened and he rescued
her too he saved her oh all right all
right
i've seen that movie plenty of times
i've never saved a woman yeah there you
go
yeah that's interesting
i love babe as a kid i eat pork
i don't know something yeah and you've
been with some pigs
all right
everybody relax
disney
uh
no that's a good bit though it never
caused something we'll figure it out and
there's all there's other disney movies
you could uh
you could you could go to
uh before we get out of here taylor
tomlinson's got a new podcast check it
out sad in the city it's great i was on
episode where we argue about uh new york
versus la you're gonna love it it's uh
it's about being sad and i love that i
get her to come here and she's like i'll
do a pocket i'm like what are you gonna
call she's like sad in the city i'm like
all right
well about my life with you
but no it's really good you'll like it a
lot it's uh people it's already doing
great it's got great numbers and uh it's
very relatable we all get uh we all get
bummed out in this town let's be honest
what uh you got dates mark yeah well let
me let me plug my ladies pot if we're
doing the ladybug my lady has a pod
called uh risky business
risque business and uh we were had
true crime oh that's great yeah yeah i
didn't know it was a true crime i knew i
knew that she had a podcast but i didn't
know it was true it's got the the
business one and uh the true crime one
so yeah give those a give those a gander
risque business risque
uh but yeah i got a ton of dates
i'm all over the road
marknomancomedy.com syracuse
this weekend i don't know when this
comes out and uh sacramento la jolla
kansas city
i'm going off memory it's all clear i'm
doing sacramento and la jolla too in
february oh nice we're circling each
other we're always circling always
always
come see both of us columbus ohio omaha
fort wayne uh let's see la jolla tampa
back to side splitters it's been too
long there
jj
jd
bt bt
sorry i'm dyslexic bt it's been a while
can't wait to come down to table better
than tb i'll tell you
bring us bring us a picture of beer
every seven minutes until someone passes
out i bring us one every ten all right
oh yeah i got the dts
but uh yeah come on out say hello
i got i got uh magoobies this weekend
and timonium uh maryland it's it's way
better than the name trust me yes we got
uh huntsville alabama uh we just added
that so get tickets i'm sure i'm gonna
sell horribly in that market so please
see me in alabama then we got hartford
connecticut sacramento san diego orlando
west palm columbus uh
city salt lake city one of my fav one of
my favorite clubs in the country uh
cleveland uh new york city the beacon
it's going to sell out so get on it
toronto all that [ __ ] get on at
samurail.com shows playa oh albany yeah
there you go nashville yeah so it's
gonna be great a lot of good rooms good
rooms really seemed to care about what i
have no idea
all right all right oh by the way the
huntsville that's where you'll get the
uh are you laughing about the jew jokes
which side
that'll be interesting huntsville is a
progressive city actually nasa's there
nasa yeah so you get that mix of
hillbillies and
scientists
[Laughter]
well make sure to sign up for the
patreon we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com to email us peeves jokes
wrecks cocktails we love you stay safe
guys
comedy
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you